[Musique]
allez ouvrons notre dossier huit cent
mille personnes en quatre semaines ont
été touchées par la grippe et en paca
le pic de l'épidémie n'a pas encore été
atteint c'est une information du réseau
sentinelles de l'inserm
l'occasion pour nous de nous intéresser
à une unité de recherche unique en
france
elle est spécialisée dans les maladies
infectieuses des chasseurs de virus et
de bactéries en fait à l'hôpital de la
timone reportage d'olivier gerbi et de
ludovic me rendre saviez-vous qu'en ce
moment même
dix mille milliards de bactéries sont
prêtes dans votre corps à se livrent une
guerre sans merci des votre repas
terminé dans sa forteresse
ultra-sécurisée de l'hôpital de la
timone
didier rahout professeur de médecine les
connaît bien ces bactéries un univers un
peu particulier que ce laboratoire car
ici débarquent tous les jours des
échantillons envoyés par les hôpitaux du
monde entier l'objectif de didier rahout
est alors de faire parler ces virus non
identifié dans cette unité high tech
composé d'une centaine de chercheurs son
équipe des bus que les virus les plus
coriaces
le dernier en date en 2008 le mamavirus
un agent potentiel de la pneumonie le
plus gros virus au monde premier
peut-être qu'il est une contribution il
y à des virus
pourtant bien connue qui donne
régulièrement des épidémies
considérables comme la grippe actuelle
ou comme l'épidémie de gastro-entérite
tous les ans et à 3 4 5 millions gastro
entérite en france et on voit que nous
ne sommes pas capables de contrôler ça
et c'est la même chose au niveau
hospitalier pour les bactéries et pour
les virus
notre capacité à contrôler la diffusion
donc la contagion actuelle est très
faible
on sait pas lutter contre ça si un virus
mutant qui apparaît virus respiratoires
mutants avec la même contagiosité
compte tenu de notre incapacité à lutter
contre la contagion parce qu'on ne sait
pas le faire par manque de connaissances
et aussi par manque d'organisation
sociale eh bien on ont fait face
désastre considérable une fois analysées
si les russes cogen la collection comme
on l'appelle ici près de trois mille
spécimens sont ainsi enfermés dans le
plus gros laboratoire microbiologique de
france on y retrouve quelques bacille de
la peste et autres méningite mais en ce
moment l'unité de recherche s'intéresse
plus particulièrement aux bactéries
véhiculée par les poupe et l'éthique car
la priorité pour didier rahout et de
mieux connaître le processus de
contagion un mystère chez l'être humain
et on n'a pas travaillé d'une manière
extensive sur le sur la contagion et la
raison est que pour pouvoir travailler
sur la contagion il faut avoir à la fois
les malades contagieux les capacités de
les isoler les capacités de travail et
manière très professionnelle et très
très technologique sur les risques de
contagion par exemple si quelqu'un a une
grippe et bien
et qui est dans une pièce isolée dans
une grippe aspirer l'air analysé le
nombre de virus card ensuite analysées
ou est-ce que les virus se déposent
comment tout ça se transmet sont des
choses qu'on ne connaît pas pour mener à
bien ses recherches
didier rahout souhaite créer d'ici
quatre ans 1 infection paul une unité
d'une centaine de lits qui regrouperait
un corps médical au complet et des
outils technologiques dernier cri
un enjeu de taille selon lui car il aime
rappeler ce chiffre éloquent 25 % des
cancers dans le monde sont d'origine
infectieuse
[Musique]